there's tom brady oh
baby ooh under armour cleat watch the
watch yes
uh brought to you by under armour
there's no brace on the left knee uh oh
looking good tom oh look at him moving
with that 5-2
speed the ball that i hope that's a
special effect
either that's a special effect or they
need to see what they dip that football
in but tom brady working out
tom brady selling under armour i like
that and uh no
no brace he had pretty serious surgery
on the knee
yeah he said that himself crazy never
showed up
speaking of knee injuries that never
showed up on the other one report last
year
there's one there and he he spoke about
it last month
and he got into a lot of detail and you
know it'd be nice to spend a season not
having to tend to the knee all the time
and worry about the knee and i asked the
league any
comment on this you know tom brady never
was on the injury report with a knee and
no comment
of course no comment because again we
got cheaters in here
folks they all cheat they all cheat
they're all looking for an edge
sorry it's true yeah they're all hiding
things on the reports and
chris chris i i know we're supposed to
talk about brady but i just need to
emphasize this
right whether it's the injury report
whether it's that very casual
attitude that bill cower expressed to ed
bouchette
in promoting his new book about he's not
trouble with spygate because everybody
cheats and it's only cheating if you get
caught
in an age of rapidly
proliferating legalized gambling
there is going to be a point
where it all potentially falls down
and if the cheating gets exposed the
cheating is undermining the integrity of
the wagers if cheating is happening
that's what the league doesn't want to
talk about but it needs to
and it needs to be thinking about it
because all it takes is one
scandal big enough yeah that affects
enough of the hard-working dollars of
the people out there who are wagering
legally
when it's illegal who cares hey that's
what you get for placing illegal wagers
too bad you should have gotten lottery
tickets instead
but when it's legal that's when it
changes
and one scandal big enough means there's
going to be some sort of an
agency there's going to be some sort of
an oversight the nfl is going to lose
ultimate control of its sport if it's
not careful so
that that's if people think oh why do
you care why do you care why do you care
that's why that's why i care yeah
because i don't think the nfl is better
off
having some independent third party
coming in telling it how to run its show
no no
listen mike i mean it's a real thing
you're right there's no doubt about that
and it's a real thing
every week on every team in the nfl as
far as what can we hide and what do we
not have to put out there on the injury
report
what can we get away with with a guy
just saying oh it's maintenance or
anything like that
it's part of the business and that's
probably where you know again
you know with all the new money and all
that you're probably going to need an
independent
doctor or somebody in the team facility
that the nfl has to make sure that
things are
following protocol or anything like that
to your point so
that's very real um anything else you
want here's
here's the challenge though here's the
challenge and and i
sensed this within the last 10 years if
you aggressively apply
the rules whether it's tampering injury
reports whatever the rules are the rules
that are readily being broken
if you aggressively enforce the message
that you send
to the average person is man it is a
they are all cheaters
they are all cheaters yeah it's you know
they got this one they got this one they
got this one they got this one
get back to us when you find somebody
who isn't cheating that's the perception
they're trying to avoid and they
desperately need to avoid it
in this new age here's bruce arians
yesterday talking about tom brady's
ongoing recovery
from that pretty serious knee surgery
even though the knee injury was never on
the report last year
i don't know how much i'll let him do
you know with guys chasing him around
we'll see we'll see see what the doctors
say and
and he may be doing a lot of coaching
so at mandatory mini camp when tom brady
will be there currently what what a
strange
scenario the buccaneers have they have a
certain number of guys
who are over there at the yankees
facility
working out with tom brady right and
then they got the other guys who are
in their facility and tom brady will be
there for the mandatory mini camp but
again they're being careful with that
knee pretty serious surgery on the knee
and they're making sure he's ready to go
when the season rolls around as they
should oh come on we know he'll be ready
i mean there's just there's nobody been
ever been more diligent with their body
in the history of
maybe sports especially football with
brady i mean he's probably got people
looking over his leg and knee
24 7. he does everything right he's
probably found the right
food that you know strengthens the
ligament and takes away
you know the the swelling he's he's
amazing that way
i mean i just again i can't say enough
about brady and even that little
video there i mean his body the way he's
transformed it the way he looks it's
crazy i'm saying that
but i mean man i saw him as a younger
guy i saw him when i worked there 10
years ago
his body wasn't as good as it is now it
just shows you that
you know what he does and this the
attention the detail and everything like
that and
you know i just i know people think i
don't like tom brady but it's just not
the fact and you know the other thing i
like too
i just think he cheated well yeah i
think he took care of the ball wide
spread
that's it you think he cheated okay well
i do i think he took the air to the ball
that's it
other than other than that somebody else
did well i'll never
hear i mean but everything else i i will
never say like anything negative about
him i mean i just think he's
he's awesome even in that little video
there he's throwing a football
and he like yells out there i can
picture what he's doing
i've seen him do it in person yeah go
ahead play it like watch there's
there's this one ball he throws to his
right and he kind of yells at the
receiver and he
or something like that and it's coming
up here i think maybe with the next
throw
but it's such a tom brady thing because
i saw him do that in practice in new
england
it's a great way to like kind of get
energy for the football team and it
might be it's coming up here i just
wanted to see it so everybody can like
enjoy it here it is maybe sure it's this
one say oh
right like he's great in that stuff we
used to warm up in new england and
listen i wasn't always allowed on the
practice field but i'd have to go catch
balls and things like that
and he'd start throwing some balls and
he'd get loose and he'd start
oh the rifle's out i'm throwing lasers
today
and it's just lasers you can't handle
that receivers and doing stuff like that
and it's it
infected the whole team it woke
everybody up gave everybody energy and
that's where i love tom brady
did you saw also have the best hands in
the organization when you were with the
patient
nobody randy moss that you had the best
hands on the title yeah yeah no nobody
cared about
me in new england nobody gave a damn and
i think a lot of the times that they saw
me caught a ball they were like hey get
that jerk
back in the building to break something
down that's kind of how it went down
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports